248 millions de touristes dont près de
94 millions d'étrangers ont visité
l'italie en 2018 à eux seuls ils ont
dépensé 42 milliards d'euros
mais cette année l'italie devra se
passer de la majeure partie de cette
manne financière comme ici à ce père
longa ville côtière de 3000 habitants
située entre rome et naples
la population de cette station balnéaire
bordée par la mer tyrrhénienne a été en
partie épargnées par le virus mais pas
son économie le tourisme représente 50 %
de notre pib
l'autre moitié étant l'agriculture et la
production agricole
le pib de l'italie est basée sur les
secteurs du tourisme pour une part de 10
à 15% tandis que la moitié du pib de ce
père longa est basée sur le tourisme
soit la moitié de son économie totale de
la soie économies en temps normal à
cette période de l'année
bars et restaurants sont déjà pleins as
peyrelongue a mais seul règne
aujourd'hui les terrasses vides et les
plages désertes
un manque à gagner colossal pour les
professionnels de la restauration qui
continuent de payer leurs charges sans
glaner le moindre euro
nous sommes très conscients que nous
sommes dans une période dont nous ne
sortirons pas avec des bénéfices mais
nous aimerions moins limiter les dégâts
et payer nos employés couvrir les
dépenses
lorsqu'elles tombent tous les jours même
si tout est fermé ici nous recevons
toujours les factures elles arrivent
régulièrement comme toutes les autres
dépenses
il n'y a rien de mise en place pour nous
aider nous ne sommes en aucune façon
protéger nous avons déjà perdu 90 % de
nos revenus habituels
nous sommes fermés je ne vois pas de
solution
je dirais même 100 % de nos revenus car
il n'y en a pas du tout cas ce qu'espère
longa comme ailleurs dans le pays
on attend donc la fin du confinement et
la réouverture des bars si les italiens
pourront de nouveau sortir à partir du 4
mai les restaurants ne pourront eux
redémarrer leurs activités qu'à partir
du 1er juin des commerces qui pour ne
pas faire faillite devront donc compter
sur le tourisme intérieur